tensions are high once again between
russia and ukraine moscow's deploying
troops along the border and kiev is
warning of a possible invasion but
what's triggered this crisis and can it
be contained this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
imran khan
ukraine is accusing russia of mobilizing
tens of thousands of soldiers near their
shared border the movement of russia's
41st army units has raised fears a
military offensive might be on the way
it's the second time this year moscow is
amassed combat ready forces in the
region on friday ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky said russia was
planning a coup to overthrow his
government moscow rejected those
allegations and blamed kiev and the u.s
for the escalating tensions
president joe biden says he's likely to
speak to both leaders to ease the
dispute russia seized ukraine's at
crimea region in 2014 and backs
separatist territories in the east nato
has warned moscow that any attempt to
invade ukraine would have serious
consequences
we'll get to our guest shortly but first
this update from charles stratford in
eastern ukraine
russia's intentions of course remain
unclear but one thing is certain and
that's moscow continuously denying that
it has any intention of invading ukraine
and that's the kind of language the kind
of accusations that are being made by
certain western leaders and the
international media language that the
kremlin has described as being both
malicious and hysterical
we also know though that president putin
is very unhappy with the ukrainian
leadership here describing it as foot
dragging in implementing its side of a
peace agreement signed in 2015 an
agreement that many analysts say is very
much weighted in russia's favor and
could potentially give russia
too much control of ukrainian internal
affairs meanwhile the international
community ukraine's allies in nato the
u.s france and germany for example
warning russia of serious consequences
if indeed there was to be a further
escalation but it remains to be seen
just how far they would go
to protect ukraine if indeed such a
disaster was to happen
charles stratford for inside story in
avivka eastern ukraine
the annexation of crimea in 2014
worsened ties between the west and
russia
moscow seized the region from ukraine in
march 2014 prompting international
condemnation and sanctions
and the following month war broke out in
eastern ukraine between russian-backed
separatists and the ukrainian army more
than 13 000 people have been killed in
the fighting and at one point about a
1.5 million people were displaced now in
2015 france and germany brokered a peace
agreement but efforts to reach a
political settlement have failed
let's bring in our guests joining us
live from kiev alexey haran a professor
at the kiev molya academy and the
director of research at democratic
initiatives foundation from fairfax
virginia john herbst he's the senior
director of the atlantic council's
eurasian center and a former u.s
ambassador to the ukraine and from
moscow pavel felgenhauer he's a defense
and military analyst and a columnist for
nueva gazetta a warm welcome to you all
let's begin in kiev first with alexi
haran there's no way vladimir putin is
actually going to invade is he
well we don't know we don't know what
are the calculations of putin we need to
know that actually
putin invaded ukraine in 2014
he announced crimea in violation of all
the international agreements including
russian ukrainian treaty and then he
moved his regular troops in donbass in
the east of ukraine so
putin invaded ukraine russian troops are
there
and despite all the agreements that were
signed regarding
uh
and the first ceasefire was
signed in 2014 the next in 2015.
you have numerous ceasefires now you
have also ceased fire
but i've just checked the report the
daily report of special monitoring
mission of osce organization for
uh security and cooperation in europe
and just
yesterday there were 800
violations of ceasefire one
day so basically there is ongoing
russian ukrainian war with ups and downs
we don't see military large military
offensive right now but at any time
there could be possibility of that
but so alexi what you're saying is
effectively the war never ended from
2014 that there's been
yeah i see that you are sincerely
surprised but this is a fact
because on uh
[Music]
as i have said crimea is occupied
and in donbass
uh
one third of the bus which is around two
percent of ukrainian territory is
occupied by russia and
its puppet
regimes and there there are violations
every day
and ukrainian soldiers and civilians are
being killed
well let's bring in pavel felgenhauer
here from moscow what do you make of
those comments that the war never ended
that civilians are dying every day
um
yes it didn't really end there is no
political solution and skirmishes have
continued in the donbas for many years
already uh though the line of control
has not changed
so it's a kind of standing it's the
conflict you can't call it fully frozen
because skirmishes continue
but it's a very low level
and but
since there is no political solution and
right now
there seems to be no meaningful
negotiations even planned
and the normandy so-called format has
been also frozen
that means there's a possibility of
escalation of the fighting and the
rhetoric on both sides is becoming
increasingly toxic i mean on all sides
and that's a very dangerous situation
it's not an imminent conflict maybe
escalation but it's potentially very
serious and could come in
months
or maybe even a number of weeks uh paul
just talk to me about
vladimir putin's thinking why now and
why this level of escalation
well the level of escalation has been
building up
uh during the years and especially and
the in the year 21. we're lucky that it
didn't break out into a big region of
war
but the threat is there
moscow has said many times that there
are red lines that integration of
ukraine into nato and uh the appearance
of nato american military assets on
ukrainian territory is totally
unacceptable for russia
meaning that most likely russia's
in the last resort is ready to go to war
to prevent that
but there is a possibility of still
resolving the thing without a
confrontation but with each passing
month the possibility of a regional war
is growing
well one of the players in the in the
conflict will be or is in fact uh joseph
biden the u.s president we have the
former u.s ambassador to the ukraine
john herbst uh sat with us in fairfax
john i mean
is he he's in a rock and a hard place
like how does biden deal with this if he
doesn't act on ukraine he's going to be
seen as being weak but if he does act
there's a there's a threat to russia
there
um look
i think bob understands well
the dangers of the current situation
um
moscow launched an aggressive war
against ukraine in 2014 which continues
to this day
they seized crimea and they began this
covert military operation in donbass
the covert military operation dunbas was
designed to pressure kiev to pursue to
end its pursuit of a western leaning for
foreign policy
putin's operation done bosses failed
this limited limited military aggression
in dunbas has not moved ukraine in the
direction he wants that's why he's
threatening escalation
biden recognizes an escalation would be
a very bad thing for american interests
that's why he stated very clearly and
his secretary of state and secretary of
defense have stated very clearly
that there will be punishing additional
sanctions on russia if putin escalates
substantially
we are also sending more military
supplies to ukraine so the ukraine will
better be able to defend itself
now it's true the russian military is
much stronger than ukrainian military
and russian probably sees any point in
ukraine
it wants to if it uses its full
conventional military forces including
its air force including its navy
but it's also true that many russian
soldiers will die in that case
and the russian public has said multiple
times in polls conducted by the levata
center they don't want russian troops
fighting in ukraine and they don't want
russia to be fighting against ukraine
so for putin to escalate substantially
is a very serious gamble and binding i
think is speaking in clear
and strong terms about what would happen
if putin doesn't
in kiev uh alexi you've just heard what
our guest in uh virginia has had to say
now
ukraine gets a lot of military aid from
the u.s government already it's been
getting it since
2014 it's got a partner effectively in
the u.s is the u.s going to be able to
be a broker for peace here or do you
think their role is it's far too
complicated for that
for something as simple as that
look first of all uh
we we here since 2014 we hear russian
propagandas that
uh russia needs to invade ukraine
because of threat from nato and this is
totally a lie
because before those actually in 2014
ukraine had non-bloc status
supporters of nato in ukraine we are
always in minority
because we ukrainians believed that we
could have good pragmatic relations with
russia
we had a treaty with russia we had a
budapest memorandum where russia
promised to be a guarantor of ukrainian
territorial integrity
so there were no talk about nato in 2014
and then in 2014
russian aggression started and it
completely changed the views of
ukrainians
that we saw that in any case
but even if ukraine is outside of nato
even if ukraine is a neutral country it
doesn't prevent from russian
aggression
that's why definitely we need the
support from the west
and we understand
that nobody will fight for ukraine
because we are not in nato so what we
are asking since
2014 is uh
military help
unfortunately this military help was
belated
president obama didn't provide for this
help
the javelins anti-tank
weapons
ukrainians started to receive only under
trump administration so i would say that
the military support
is quite limited
and uh
what russia is saying that oh we had a
red line because of nato because of
american built up in ukraine again
totally alive because russian troops are
incited inside ukraine russia is
occupying ukraine so what is important
definitely at this point is the increase
of military support first of all and
then second point to one russia about
extension of economic sanctions now
there are economic sanctions against
russia what is important is to warn
putin that in case of attack it will
have dramatic consequences for russia in
economic sphere
let's bring in pavel falgenhauer here in
moscow where's the wiggle room where's
the negotiation
room here if president biden does follow
up on his
comment that he will speak to both the
leaders of kiev and moscow in order to
try and de-escalate the situation
what's he going to go in
and negotiate
oh yes there's a salad being prepared
right now both washington and
uh moscow white house and the kremlin
are working on the agenda it should
happen before new year it's going to be
virtual it's going to be kind of a maybe
a screen and telephone conversation but
ukraine is going to be very high on the
agenda
apparently moscow hopes that
brinkmanship that's being right now used
uh the threat of a possible
regional war with the threat of an
escalation into all european or i don't
know global conflict uh that that will
move the united states to
change somewhat its position to put
pressure on kiev to become more flexible
and uh
give russia what it wants on the
so-called
agreements
uh so that's most likely right now going
to be the thing because there's a lot of
talk of russian forces on the border
they are there for some time already
but the time of year right now is wrong
for any kind of major military
escalation a winter campaign can begin
in
second half of january but not earlier
than that so now is the time for
negotiations and apparently they will be
happening but how intense
and how effective they're going to be is
not clear
well let's bring in uh john herbst here
i mean
our guest in moscow says the
negotiations are not clear but they do
need to happen what can the americans
offer and what would the russians take
in order to de-escalate
um i don't think i don't think
negotiation is necessary at all
i think what's needed is a strong
warning to putin about the nasty things
that will happen to his cronies himself
and russia if in fact putin escalates
his uh aggression against ukraine
and again talking about major sanctions
talking about military assistance to
ukraine is the way to go
um the war in dunbas could end when
putin decides that it's no longer in his
interest
then negotiations will be important but
negotiations aren't important right now
what's important right now is a strong
stand that becomes the basis for
eventual negotiations
but this needs to meet with biden in
order not to escalate that's fine
but what again the most important thing
to prevent this from becoming
a wider war is a very strong warning to
putin about the dangerous things that
will happen
to him to russia if he again escalates
aggression yeah but that only works if
biden actually follows through i mean
you're giving the javelin anti-tank
defense systems already you've got
billions of dollars worth of military
aid going to the ukraine all of those
things russia says actually have
escalated the situation those need to be
withdrawn and then we might be able to
talk
i mean you've got to follow it through
right right
but this you see what what you've just
outlined is i think parvo's logic and
pablo's logic is correct that putin is
trying via brinksmanship to gain
concessions why in the world should we
accept this
you know the the the the situation
around ukraine is certainly dangerous
and it become more dangerous
but it's not as dangerous as the berlin
crisis in 1961 the cuban missile crisis
in 1962
when when kremlin brinkmanship um
brought the world to uh thermonuclear
war the threshold of thermonuclear war
we are much stronger than russia today
um there's no reason why we need to
panic
so again we we produce a strong reaction
i think biden is doing that
and then the russians want to talk
that's fine
but the most important thing is that
strong reaction so putin knows the
consequences the nasty consequences for
his team if in fact he escalates
actually i'm going to bring you in here
in just a moment but i do want to hear
from pavel in moscow what do you make of
john herb's comments
um well we hear from ref here in moscow
different opinions coming out of
washington um
in the present situation
even from the biden administration but
though of course there have been
warnings there have been contacts there
will be most likely more uh
in moscow we also have different
opinions they're those of the diplomatic
the foreign ministry defense ministry
kind of party of war guys who believe
that now is a good time to maybe have a
final solution of the ukrainian problem
and there are those in
with
the uh president putin surrounding to
believe that that's a bad idea that
russia will
very be
come under very serious economic
financial sanctions and that's not good
that's bad for internally and externally
and putin is a kind of balance between
these different opinions and he has the
final solution
last spring a
really big russian contingent i mean uh
hundreds of thousands of were mobilized
and the concentration of forces in the
black sea and the uh on the ukrainian
border was much higher than today
but uh putin didn't give the go-ahead
and we don't have a war in 21 we won't
have it
so it's possible that we
come to the brink and then retreat from
it uh but a
more consolidating message coming from
washington would be better than is
hearing different kind of voices
um america if it was up to john herbst
would definitely have your back do you
believe that uh president joe biden is
got has the ukraine's best interests at
heart do you think he's your guy
look every country is well what what i
think biden knows ukraine very well
when he was vice president in obama's
administration he was actually
responsible for relations with
uh with ukraine and he knows ukraine
very well he knows the reforms pro
process in ukraine so he understands
ukraine i would say said
um
what we need also to understand is that
basically we look this is politics you
know and
we don't know what exactly putin will do
as pavel said
uh
putin may be only just you know
increasing stakes
in the gamble but what he would like to
receive he
then he would decrease the stakes and he
would like to receive something
in exchange that's the whole idea that's
what happened in spring 2000 spring this
year because i believe that why putin
increased tension
is to push through north stream too so
basically he
created large armament to build up on
the border on ukraine then he withdrawn
he said okay you see i'm not going to
war let's push for north stream too
instead
so that's what putin would like to have
i guess
i hope that president biden and his
administration would
uh they do understand what putin wants
and they would back ukraine look putin
would be putin would announce peace with
ukraine if ukraine capitulates if
ukraine accepts putin terms
uh of peace putin said okay i'm fine
with so the problem is that uh
united states and europe they do not
sacrifice ukrainian national interests
that's important
john herbs where is nato in all of this
well nato i think is playing a
an important role in the current crisis
um we've seen an increase in
nato ships in the black sea
um as a way of sending a signal to
moscow
oh so it clearly has a role
but i think you see an even greater role
played by individual nato countries
starting with the united states
but also um canada
the uk
and poland and the baltic nations who
all all understand in very clear fashion
the threat of what mr putin is up to
along ukraine's borders
one final comment then from pavel
falgenhauer you've heard what john herbs
has to say about nato's role surely
that's the one thing that really does
anger uh vladimir putin and behind a lot
of what is going on right now surely
well the extension of nato is seen as
the ultimate threat for quite some years
already and that's being the backbone of
putin's foreign policy to resist the
nato extension and but it's not only of
course nato say sweden is not a member
of nato but it's right now providing
help and training uh help to you're the
ukrainian so it's not even more than
nato it's kind of the west
uh acting to try and balance the russian
pressure on ukraine
this is a what i'm really afraid of i
should say if the troops begin to move
somewhere in january both nato begins to
execute its plan 30 30 plus 30 moving
actually troops from european countries
from america actually uh to romania and
poland russia begins moving troops if we
go into that stage of the
confrontation it would be very hard to
backpedal
i want to thank all our guests alexi
haran uh
john herbst and pablo falgenhauer and i
want to thank you guys as well for
watching now you can see the program
again anytime by visiting our website
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story and you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside story from me imran khan and
the whole team here bye for now
[Music]
you